The security features in our operating
systems are designed to stay on all the
time by default, but there will be times
when you need to do additional
troubleshooting. If you need to enable
or disable the Windows firewall, you can
use the control panel or what I'll use
today in this video is the Windows
security app. You do need elevated
permissions to turn on or turn off the
firewall. So, make sure you have the
administrator permissions that you'll
need to be able to perform that
function. And if you recall from our
previous video on using the Windows
firewall from the control panel app,
there are separate profiles for each
network type. On my network, there is a
domain network profile, private network,
and public network. So from our Windows
front end, I'll go to the search option.
We'll type in security. And the first
option at the top is the Windows
security app. When this launches, you'll
have the option for virus and threat
protection, account protection, and
others. And the one we're looking for is
the firewall and network protection.
Here it brings up the main screen of the
firewall and network protection. And it
shows all three of the profiles that are
currently configured on my system for
domain network, private network, and
public network. You can enable and
disable the Windows firewall directly
from the control panel. We did that in a
previous video, but in this video, we're
going to use the Windows security app.
If we click the profile for private
network, it tells us that this is
network 5. That's the adapter that's in
my Windows system. And you can see that
Windows Defender Firewall is toggled on.
If we click that toggle, it prompts the
user account control to present a screen
that says, "Do you want to allow this
app to make changes to your device?" In
this case, the app is the Windows
Security app. And in this case, yes, we
do. We'd like to disable the firewall.
When we do that, we can see that the
toggle has changed to off. And there's a
new message on the screen telling us
that the private firewall is off and
your device may be vulnerable. To turn
this back on, we reverse the process by
clicking the toggle. It asks us again if
we want to allow this app, the security
app, to make changes to our device. We
will say yes, and our Windows Defender
firewall is back
on. One of the options available within
each firewall profile is the option for
incoming connections. This will allow us
to enable or disable incoming
connections when we are on a private
network. We can enable this by clicking
the box that says blocks all incoming
connections, including those in the list
of allowed apps. So, if we've created a
rule that allows a particular firewall
to communicate by clicking that box, we
will block that connection even though
it's already in that list of allowed
apps. This is useful if you're on an
unknown network or maybe you're on a
public wireless network and you want to
be sure that no other device on that
network has access to your computer.
Back inside our private network profile,
the option for modifying the incoming
connections is at the bottom. And if we
click that box, user account control
asks, do you want to allow this app to
make changes to your device? Yes, we do.
And now we are blocking all incoming
connections, even if we've already
created a rule to allow that app. To
remove that restriction, we simply
reverse the process by clicking the box
again. It asks if we'd like to make
changes. We do. And now we're back to
where we
started. There are also notification
settings within Windows Firewall and
with our other security features. And we
can configure those notification options
under firewall and network protection
notifications. And we can toggle on and
off by different profiles. You'll find
those notification options from the main
screen of the firewall settings. If we
look all the way down, you'll see
firewall notification settings. This
will bring up a link for managing these
notifications, and we can manage virus
and threat protection notifications,
account protection notifications. And if
we scroll all the way to the bottom, you
will find firewall and network
protection notifications. You can turn
those on or off, and this will notify
you when Microsoft Defender firewall
blocks a new app. And then you can
enable or disable which profiles will be
active for these notifications. By
default, my domain firewall and public
firewall is turned on. Let's say that we
would also like to enable these
notifications for my private profile.
I'll click that option. It asks if I'd
like to make those changes. I would. And
now those notification options are
enabled for my private
profile. There might also be times when
we're not sure if we're using the
built-in Windows Defender firewall or if
we may have installed a third-party
firewall. The way that you determine
that is in the option for security
providers. From the main screen of the
firewall and network protection, we'll
choose the option for firewall
notification settings. And at the very
top is security providers. We can click
the option to manage those providers.
And it will tell us which anti virus,
firewall, and web protection providers
are running on this system. For anti
virus, the system is running Microsoft
Defender Antiirus. It gives you
information that you can use to open
that app. We also have the firewall
that's running on the system which is
Microsoft firewall and the firewall is
turned on and we have no providers
currently enabled for web protection on
this system.